there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
hey kid i'm a little young for a
bartender aren't you a little old for
prom aren't you
falling all around
everything in here why the map this path
ferdinand magellan took the sail around
the world you know your history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found 5 billion easy
to go
i think you're here because you're your
brother well you know my brother said
i'm a friend of sully's sally doesn't
have any friends i should know him one
of them
[Music]
you're a collector well i dabbled i
don't know
my family has been looking for this
portion for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother say i'm one
final clue
guess i'll keep
oh my god i should never come out to
play with that big boy's way in because
you're about to get a proper scottish
welcome
what oh crap
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you